this is Quentin Tennessee Christmas
planner 1956
population 4,000 that's the high school
basketball team in action against Lake
City they lost 63 to 43 last year they
won at a good football season this year
in spite of all the recent rubble
the Clinton pep band plays rock around
the clock and to all outward appearances
it's just another night in just another
Tennessee community but Main Street has
not always been by it
there have been mobs in the square
before the courthouse and Wyatt's had
had to be broken up by the National
Guard and a white baptist minister was
beaten up on Broad Street the violence
in Clinton was news all over America and
much of the rest of the world but this
is not a report on the National Guard in
Clinton or the tanks in the street or
the tear gas or the burning crosses but
rather an examination after the fact
filmed in Clinton
between December 4 when the Reverend
Turner was attacked and now it is an
attempt by see it now and the citizens
of Clinton to explore the chain of
events and emotions which brought
violence and shame and hope to this town
all the persons to be heard during the
60 minute report will be citizens of
Clinton with the exception of Judge
Robert L Taylor of Knoxville and John
Casper of Washington both active
participants in the conflict of the four
thousand people who live in Clinton more
than 3,700 are white and by tradition
and custom most of them believe in
separate school in 1950 Negro parents
backed by the National Association for
the Advancement of Colored People
brought suit against the Anderson County
school system which administers Clinton
high school asking that their children
be admitted the courrier news the
Clinton weekly spoke for the community
and support of segregation editor Horace
weld or any newspaper is inclined to
follow the thinking of the majority of
the people in the community and this
community and and I myself have favored
segregation all down through the years
back when this lawsuit was filed in 1950
we did everything we could
to maintain segregation about trying to
provide the Negro students with good
equal but separate facilities and that
was where the community fails and that's
where the community wanted it and that
was editorial policy this newspaper the
federal judge in this section of
Tennessee in 1951 and now is Robert L
Taylor of Knoxville the Anderson County
school case was before my court about
five years ago at that time I held that
the colored children were not entitled
to enter the Clinton high school because
they were being furnished equal but
separate facilities at that time the
equal but separate facility dr. was the
law the Negroes appealed a judge
Taylor's decision and when the Supreme
Court decision of May 1954 ruled against
segregation judge Taylor's ruling was
reversed on january 4 1956
the ordered Anderson County to comply
it is hip team of this court that
desegregation as to high school students
in that County should be effective by a
definite date and that a reasonable date
should be fixed as one not later than
the beginning of the fall term of the
present year of nineteen hundred and
fifty-six accordingly on August 20 1956
approximately seven hundred students
registered for the fall opening without
incident 12 of them were Negroes judge
Taylor told them all to obey the law and
there seemed to be no questions then
another voice was heard in Clinton John
Casper an outsider a white supremacist
told them that the law need not be
obeyed our failure today has been
failing to attack failing to attack
failing to attack at every level and
continuously but we in the white
Citizens Council say now yesterday today
and forever as long as there is one
living white man the United States the
Supreme Court is not the law of the land
that decision is nothing all the land
now or never will be never
John Kasparov first came to Clinton on
August 25 and threatened to close up the
school if desegregation continuing
Gosford had certain qualities of
leadership and there were those in
Clinton willing to be led 103 days later
his boast was back an organized campaign
of picketing threats dynamiting and
rioting that brought Clinton to the
brink of anarchy
Gasper has been arrested twice but
continues to lead the battle against
Judge Taylor's order school attendance
shrunk by parents fear of violence was
at times as low as 260 the pressure
mounted on everyone the faculty the
parents the student this is Jerry Chabot
captain of the football team and an
all-state guard talking to reporter
Arthur Morse in the gymnasium how did
the students react the first day that
they that the Negroes came to class well
I'd like to say something about two or
three weeks preceding the time school
starting you know our school starts at
the 1st of September and all through the
month of August of course we knew we
would have Negro students in school
that's when we started but no one said
too much about it and no one seemed to
oppose to it violently and then I
believe it was the Saturday before the
Monday that school started this Casper
came in
and he started calling people up and
stopping them on streets and trying to
form pickets in front of school for
Monday morning and then Monday morning
when we did come to school we found that
there were Oh 15 to 20 people out there
with pickets and the students most of
them are out watching and everything
course you know is something that they'd
never seen before and then when school
started and the Negro students were
inside no one was hostile towards them
everyone seemed to be friendly all the
troubles seemed to be outside the school
among the adults and I'd say six or
seven of the students that Casper had
persuaded to picking well of course you
know that things kept adding on top of
each other and pretty soon the National
Guard came into town and of course
things quieted down in a hurry then and
then Casper left and for about a month
there a month and a half everything was
quiet and then this the local
authorities wanted to try Casper owned a
sedition and inciting a riot I think it
was and then he came into town for that
trial and then after that this
intimidation within the school that's
happened just recently started what sort
of intimidation was they go down the
halls and maybe push the negro student
or I remember they threw some Negro
students books out into the rain one day
and they poured some ink and eggs down
into the Negro students locker and I
think they threw a book at a negro
student in a study hall Jerry how do you
personally feel about having Negro
classmates well I didn't ask for
integration and I wasn't enthusiastic
about getting it but the Supreme Court
said that our high school should be
integrated and so I thought that I
should do all I could to bring this
court order about peacefully I think a
football coach said put it very well he
said all through your life you're going
to come up against things that you don't
like that he says you're going to have
to accept them anyway and just make the
best out of them that you can and that's
the way I feel about it too and I think
that that's the way most of the students
fear
the 12 colored students who came down
every morning from bully Hill also had a
lot to get used to and then Monday
morning when we started to school there
were only a few people on hand and I
thought maybe well they just here to be
curious and they wanted to see us come
in and if they would leave later but
then on the next day when things when
more people came and a young boy started
walking mcfine I began to wonder and
think well maybe they're not going to
accept this like I thought they were and
on Wednesday morning I almost tried to
go back home because there were so many
people and it looks so mainly they look
like they just wanted to grab us and
throw us out they didn't want us at all
I could just see the hate in their
hearts and when we got inside the school
most of the children was very nice to us
and then there was some you could tell
if they didn't want to scare they show
you in a big way they are precise aa
person chose to get out and they all
threw paper as they shoved us and all
this shoot I threw chalk at us hmm
said all sorts of nasty things and it
just made me feel bad and I couldn't
concentrate at all on my lesson but more
than on any other individual the brunt
of the pressure was exerted on principal
DJ Britton jr. who had fought the
original battle for segregation and was
now fighting to obey the law of the land
mr. Brittain as principal of Clinton
High School have you yourself suffered
any personal harassment since the
situation began yes sir I can frankly
say that I've suffered nothing but
personal harassment and other people to
my wife and teachers and students in the
school or anybody that took a stand to
obey the law not necessarily but they
agreed with it but in any first for
myself the first
day and night my telephone ringing
incessantly I guess my life was
threatened ten or twelve times by
anonymous telephone callers who would
all hang it up I have since had my phone
number changed four times to keep from
hitting these annoying calls I received
letters many through the mail I received
two today one of which was an unsigned
letter of course which said that they
felt that I was a roll-down person and
used other vile names and felt that
someone should throw acid in my face or
in the face of someone in my family and
that I wasn't fit to live now I have had
a number of those kind of letters now
those letters are always anonymous they
never put a name on them and our
teachers have been called names of all
kinds and they have maked it made a
department in the last few weeks to do
anything they could to make it difficult
for the teachers how would you
characterize the attitude but most of
your pupils in this situation they have
stood advice loyally me and every test
that came up and we feel that they still
do to a large degree we believe like me
we believe that there are maybe 40
students in the school who are creating
the trouble that we have at the present
time and subject to this or before this
an organization a youth organization has
been organized which was connected with
the white Citizens Council and as their
full backing and I understand has the
same goal
and these people and I have talked to
several of them in school are
encouraging other people if not doing
things themselves to drive the Negroes
out of the school now when I talk to mr.
Casper at the beginning of school he
wanted to know what I was going to do
about getting the [ __ ] in those words
out of Clinton high school and I told
him that I had three choices that I
could resign my job or I could stay with
it and obey the law or I could do what
he said and that I chose none of those
except to abide by the law as it was
stated but mr. Casper informed me that
he was interested in only two things and
those were one to drive the Negro
students out and two to get me out of my
job but here is a matter that is clearly
a decision of the United States Supreme
Court and we do not feel that if we
allow or teach our citizens to disobey
this law that they are learning the
right principles assistantship in other
words if they can do that they can
violate any other law or any other
decision in the country we've also been
working at the problem of trying to get
people to understand each other better
and be more tolerant towards each other
and one of the interesting developments
of this thing is to me has been that I'm
not being accused of being at Cummings I
was born in Tennessee I've lived my life
in Tennessee I attended Tennessee
schools I attended Merrill cards in
Tennessee to get my bachelor's degree
and master's degree at the University of
Tennessee and
there's anything about me that is
communistic I certainly do not know what
it is
and it looks to me like I've weathered
some of the attacks methods that are
being used against the schools and
against myself leaned more in that
direction than anything that I have ever
done or said quite frankly I think I can
feel like many people in Europe feel now
wife and I since the opening of school
are always careful when we go home we
study the premises when we get in we
lock the doors and get the lights on any
noise or any sound that occurs we are
always concerned at what it is there
have been some nights when we have felt
that it was the only safe thing for us
to do was to stay out of town we have
visited our friends at times it is just
a constant thing which I'm sure it is
part of the organization to where myself
and my wife now it's just presses you
down every day law and law and to me it
is an amazing thing there's an American
citizen living in Nina and States it has
to be subjected to this well the lowest
citizens those who refuse to abide or
accept the law continue to run for I
know this is not a true picture of
America and always not a true picture of
the majority of the people vanishing
Kent but it is a picture of myself in
several other citizens in Clinton who
have tried to abandon a lot the most
talked about man in Clinton
John Kasper of Washington DC John Casper
still awaiting appeal of a one-year
sentence is the self-appointed executive
secretary of the seaboard white Citizens
Council and a protege of Ezra Pound
since his two arrests he is forbidden
from interfering in Clinton but because
it is impossible to measure his full
effect on the community without
observing him in action we followed him
to nearby Kentucky on December 12 he was
speaking to a white Citizens Council
group in a fourth floor law the argument
simply does not hold that the white race
being a minority rather being a majority
in the United States should turn over to
a group of people only removed from
slavery 80 years and only removed from
the jungle by a few hundred years turned
over to them the control of our entire
civilization the basis of common law is
the custom of the people if the custom
of the people in Anderson County is to
keep the races separate then the Supreme
Court law doesn't mean anything it
doesn't John Casper on the Ku Klux Klan
in 11 years in every southern state the
segregation laws we are fighting for
today were written every one up by the
Ku Klux Klan which saved the south and
the men who stood face-to-face of
Chickamauga Braxton Bragg and General
Thomas if they didn't have a principle
to fight and die for if they said well
we'll just let this thing go on every
single one of us here tonight would be
mulatos and not right everyone John
Casper on the people of the South they
underestimated the intelligence and the
resistance power of the mountain folk
down here in Tennessee and Kentucky they
underestimated that they thought well
maybe they were dealing with a group of
held
rednecks crackers but those are the real
people the United States make no mistake
about and those Hillbillies and crackers
as Billy Branham said they're the pure
white people living in the face of the
earth anywhere and the strongest among
them are men who get on their knees and
pray every Sunday and they pray to they
pray hard they believe in that Bible and
they believe in Jesus Christ mr. Casper
tells of his Clinton adventure when I
was in Charlottesville I saw a little
piece in the Charlottesville paper which
said that integration was a coming in
Tennessee for the first time the first
school Clinton High School it happened
to be just a day away now I want to find
out how the folks felt about it I didn't
think they were for it but I didn't tell
them anything about that I just went
door-to-door I showed him a picture of a
[ __ ] soldiers kissing some white girl
and probably all seen that picture army
and the Fort McClellan Alabama some say
it's Germany doesn't make any difference
they're still [ __ ] in American army
uniforms kissing white girls then make
any difference was Germany or Alabama
being done wrong now I showed him the
picture and the IIST and they knew
brought the [ __ ] blowing the school
the next day and they said they knew
about it they heard something about it
or they didn't hear about it some of
them hadn't even heard about it I asked
them how they felt about their and they
said I'm again what can we do about
nothing
so I told him something about picketing
how labor unions operate I told him to
be down at the school the following day
now Monday morning and I would be there
with them and we ticket and we discussed
this thing with a local officials we'd
find out what if anything could be done
about it
John Casper on politicians what we are
trying to do is regain local control of
local affairs and it is less of
government local corruption we must deal
with first you can hardly expect
have a choice between a high-low pumpkin
and the hotness the hollow pumpkin on a
pole who's in the White House now and
the man who ran against them in the
recent election national election two
men both of them dedicated to stupidity
and treachery both of them doesn't mean
a thing either one of them you compare
them to the patron saint of the
Republican or Democratic Party's
Jefferson or or Lincoln or any of those
people why these men are nothing our
president today they're just sworn
enemies of the American Republic sworn
enemies of the Constitution do
everything they can their power to
destroy it have consistently for 35
years
each each and every one up John Casper
on the Supreme Court the idea is clear I
think in everybody's mind with the right
aim of law is to prevent coercion either
by force or by fraud and the Supreme
Court decision is exactly precisely
fraudulent precisely coercive but the
Supreme Court is in there for life and
the whole federal judiciary is in there
for life and there's nothing you can do
about it impeachment is silly I mean it
just it's so hard to accomplish that
probably easier to assassinate me
Supreme Court we know they're communists
we know that to combine nine men in the
Supreme Court don't make one good civil
claims judge but yet on the other hand
combined they make one of the most
deadly communists
Hydra head monsters we've ever known but
I'm absolutely confident we're going to
destroy that do I say integration can be
reversed it can be stopped anywhere
provided an attack is made at every
single level that meetings of the county
court are attended that the constant
self-same demands are made that people
people keep hitting the judge who made
the original ruling that pressure tree
men
they brought to bear on that school
principal on the school board on the
local newspaper or whoever it is it
happens to be responsible
there's no sense any longer appealing to
senator so-and-so or president or the
President or the Supreme Court judge it
got to be a pressure down here which is
more or less like a lit stick of
dynamite and you throw it in their lap
let them catch it and then they can do
what they want with it
but let them worry about at nine o'clock
on the morning of December 4 1956 was
conceivably the darkest hour of the
worst day in Clinton's history the
Reverend Paul Turner a Baptist was
beaten up after escorting six Negro
youths to school there were witnesses it
was a it was a horrible thing and I
thought they were actually killing him
blood was streaming down his face and
even it just looked that blood was
running out of his eyes
I asked someone in the group just anyone
to help him and when there was no
response I went to him and tried to
assist him by pulling some of the men's
arms for around his face and then all
the time the men in this group who were
standing around were screaming to kill
him and that's exactly what I thought
they were going to do I certainly don't
consider that it was an act of bravery
it was just a matter of the right or
wrong thing to do and I did what I
thought was right and I'm pretty not
ashamed of the fact that I did it's just
that I'm ashamed really for the people
of Fenton that it did happen in such a
nice town for if it's not people there
Reverend Turner is 33 years old I spent
all of his life in Tennessee for about
five days these Negro students having of
course the legal right to attend Clinton
high school had stayed home because of
harassment and hindrance and heckling
and threats upon their lives and
incidents that actually would make
anybody scared I chose to take such a
stand on this moral principle that as
long as the law is the law as it is in
our land and as long as they did
personally choose to come to Clinton
high school their legal right that they
had a moral right to attend uh Nicole
and unhindered and on arrest it was this
that prompted MIT to accompany them
though there were quite a few hecklers
we made our way to the high school
building without any overt incident when
I emerged from the school building about
five or ten minutes later the hecklers
were still there and they heckled me
personally about 300 yards away from the
high school we were far away from where
the policemen were doing their duty of
course in front of the high school one
of the Citizens Council members had
stationed himself with about three of
the men on a corner as I made my way to
that corner they jumped me I retreated
across the street
Bob Street of Clinton trying to keep him
at arm's length while the other fellows
were trying to surround me and to hold
my arms and get me stationary for the
beating I retreated all the way across
the street trying to avoid any incident
finally found myself pretty well backed
up against the bishop building on the
other side of the street I knew then
that I had to do something and it was at
that time also that one man successful
they held my arms down and allowed the
number one man of their game to land a
pretty good blow upon my nose it was at
that time also that I realized I had to
defend myself in some way and so I took
off after the man who had slugged me
pinned him against a car and immediately
about eight to ten people were on our
backs after a while and the police
arrived everybody scattered pretty much
we came up from our position bending
over
I took a hold of the two fellows that
led the attack one in one hand one in
the other and shoved each of them into
the arms of a policeman and from there
they took them on over to the police
station I retreated into a doctor's
office but everyone did not applaud
Reverend Turner's act which
coincidentally occurred on the same day
that Clinton was electing a new mayor
james Meredith a grocer running for
mayor with the backing of the white
Citizens Council was badly defeated
claims that the Rev run's action may
have swung the election to his opponent
my name's James P Meredith I'm operator
the city food market in Clinton
Tennessee I was in this mayor's ratio
December the 4th 1956 which I was
defeated well about the election I think
there's a lot of misrepresentation a lot
of it start here in this Clinton current
news which is a local weekly newspaper
here I've been here a resident of this
tyranny around 20 live about in 20 years
why he had representatives if I might
have been Jesse James if somebody just
come in here on a horse rode into town
got old which that was untrue
I've been here on this street for about
20-some years operating a grocery store
they made it out to be segregation
against integration as for me I'm right
there 95 percent I'd say the people here
in Anderson County are I'm against the
integration of of course we believe in
Negro having equal rights equal
education an equal facilities but we
think he should have them in their own
place as for being endorsed by the white
Citizens Council as everybody knows I
came out in this race on Mon
my friends came in the store here and
encouraged me to run this mayor's race I
was running a good race and this mayor's
race up until the morning before the
polls open why this Minister he went up
on the hill
bring the [ __ ] down to school minute
do you meditate to that why the stuff
will I hear started down some war in the
lower-end town that was a fox merit said
by ten minutes before the polls open as
to whether or not that was political I
don't know mom's den was that [ __ ]
wasn't supposed to come school at
morning but I figure I'll come back and
either two or four years from there and
win in this mayor's race there were
other merchants involved and some were
losing customers because they stood by
the court order this is our G krosno
chairman of the school board
I'm sure there's no doubt in your mind
mister my official connection with the
dairy company as president of NARS
preemie incorporated we too have heaven
threat for Carnival product in a number
of instances we had lost a couch which
we have served in for 15 years as a
result of my being a member of this
particular school board but I would like
to assure you as a faculty and my fellow
members on the board if becomes
necessary you need to make a decision
mr. February I've set a quota meal or
resign from the school board I would
like to show you here now that I will
not serve a quarter mil for will remain
a member of the school board also on
December 4th the principal's wife was
knocked down and several white and
colored children were beaten the school
board asked for federal protection and
at 11:45 closed the high school until
order could be restored
mrs. eleanor Davis a mother and a
teacher explains to a PTA group what it
was like we were stunned
there were some who were jubilant sure
they had wanted it to happen and they
rejoice but now they didn't have to go
to school and they could keep other
people from going to school
we really wanted an education but those
were few in number there were other
students who were so stunned they didn't
know whether to leave or not going down
the hall I found students crying I found
seniors who were bitter because they
felt that they might not be able to
graduate course tension had been high
and you can imagine the reaction the
various reaction after the students
laughed the faculty didn't want to leave
somehow we just couldn't leave we met
together in the Faculty room we felt
defeated we felt as if we'd raise a flag
of surrender and we did not wave a flag
of surrender we didn't want to admit
that we couldn't control the situation
it was not until the acquittal of Kasper
in our local Criminal Court and the
organisation of the Youth Council that
we began to have a breakdown within the
school the members of the Youth Council
were not all students but among those
who were students we had some habitual
troublemakers disciplinary problems
students who found it difficult to test
and some of the students who belong to
the Youth Council were so ashamed of the
fact that they had to belong that they
refused to wear their badges they had
only joined at the insistence of their
parents they refused to participate in
any of the troubleman I know because I
talked with it there are a few students
who have been so sensitive to this
situation to the things that they've
heard on our scene on the outside that
they have drawn within
and they're not the same as they used to
be they're afraid to express themselves
and they've lost that happy carefree
attitude of you of course we hope that
time will heal that and they will be
once more their happy self now I don't
think anybody can say enough concerning
the courage of the Negro students
themselves who were willing to face
persecution in their hometown to get an
education the majority of students and I
do mean a majority have undergone this
crisis with great courage and faced it
intelligently trying to be courteous and
helpful at all times and I think these
students have grown up a little bit
that Sunday with the schools still
closed and the FBI still in town
Reverend Turner faced his all-white
congregation for the first time since
his controversial act the Bible is
without precedent as a book and I
personally have no fear that it will
ever be superseded but many have tried
to misuse the Bible trying to justify
some low standard of conduct by the very
Bible that they profess to love and by
the book that never compromises with sin
with pride with prejudice or with hate
Billy Graham tells the following story
shortly after the Civil War in a very
fashionable Church in Richmond Virginia
there interred a Negro man one Sunday
morning when communion was being served
he walked down the aisle and took his
place at the altar to partake of the
elements of the Lord's Supper there was
a rustle of anger that swept through the
congregation sensing this delicate
situation a distinguished gentleman
stood up and walking down the aisle he
took his place by his colored brother
immediately his magnificent example
swept over the spirits of the rest of
the people in that congregation and they
followed him to the altar taking their
place there too this man was none other
than Robert Ely my friends we have been
too far away from God when mobs are able
in our land to flout the law the tragic
result is a Cicero Illinois or a Phoenix
City Alabama here in Clinton we are not
especially against integration we are
not especially against segregation but
we are positively and definitely against
the disintegration of our community and
our body politic that we cherish above
all things
realizing that where our energy prevails
none of us has anything of any value and
none of us has any freedoms anymore and
now we realize more clearly than ever
before that it is Christ our chaos
may we pray principal britain had
invited the county attorney eugene joyce
to tell the student body what the law
expected of them I am here this morning
in my official capacity as County
Attorney to tell you what in the future
the Board of Education and this faculty
will expect of you as students it is not
my intention to tell you what to think
nor it is my nor is it my desire to tell
you what to believe but it is my duty to
tell you how to act in the future so
long as you are students at Clinton High
School to my knowledge never in the
history of American education has it
been necessary to read an instrument
such as this to a specially called
Student Assembly I have been asked now
to read to you this injunction from the
United States District Court of the
Eastern District of Tennessee Northern
Division but even before the school had
been reopened the long arm of the
federal law had taken over u.s. marshals
had moved into Clinton and arrested 16
men and women accused of violating Judge
Taylor's injunction their arraignment
took place in nearby Knoxville on
December 10 the same day school reopened
here are eight of the defendants on
their way to the courthouse and here is
the voice of the county attorney reading
the injunction the 29th 1956 a crowd of
people agitated by one John Casper
attacked one of the Negro children of
the school that Casper stated on various
occasions that the court had no
authority to issue the aforesaid order
of desegregation in the Clinton High
School and that it should not be obeyed
it is ordered and decreed by the court
that the affirm mentioned persons their
agents servants representatives
attorneys and all other persons who are
acting or
act in concert with them be and they
hereby are enjoined and prohibited from
further hindering obstructing or in any
wise interfering with the carrying out
of the aforesaid order of this court or
from thickening Clinton high school
either by words or acts or otherwise the
young woman under arrest
is mrs. Ellen Nelson daughter of Clem
Dishman reporter Morse talked to Dishman
at his home on College Hill
this is the Clem Dishman who's lived in
Clinton for 20 years has his own garage
down in town Clem what do you think
about the situation here in Clinton way
I understand it is my daughter and the
rest of these folks here will sign up to
be a witness in this little case here at
the city of fires are fighting inside
the corporation they gather them up and
they take them over to Austin they put
them in put them in jail over they even
kept my daughter in there with I think
it's either six or seven criminal women
where I look at it just in the bullpen
and I don't can't see nothing forgot
that you see what I what what needs to
be done way I look at now these there's
only about six or eight of them here it
goes to school I think the claim is
eight
well what couldn't them people just go
to some others to they've got a cutter
studio at nozzle and then Anderson
County offered to pay their two issues
friendship Boys Ranch the gas they even
wind up one foot enough to furnish a
colored driver they ask for a colored
driver here they're just before the
pastor went up on the hill to lead them
all to die the bus they didn't notion of
going that much notion to go on well he
goes up and caused all this trouble see
the pastor of the First Baptist Church
bald hanger goes up from the hill over
here leads the color doll put some in
the sku gogo 110 in and has his back I
thank the supreme court when they ruled
that the have segregation ever work I
think they're trying to misrepresented
shortage we're look at it now I don't I
don't know too much about
over the if it'll work in one place
it'll work in another
you're working all you took justice and
now I'm in outfit or whatever you might
want to call it well over in Russia they
got the same thing although we
understand to get the same mind for that
Kent I don't think that's right I think
that's calmness we're doing Dennis now
I'll tell you what I think about that's
just what I'll think about see what I
mean you know well what do you think
about about John Casper I think John
Casper's real man I think I think you
trying to got him under a bad deal this
year in the base stuff myself now I'm
just telling from a personal self so
you're thinking that that's what I'll
think about cash today I don't think
he's firing man nowhere he just woke us
up around here and then people around
here just generally living under the way
I look at it but he just won't fess up
to the fact that we're just living on
anything anybody might want to do around
here this newspaper over here whales out
here to inspire on that stand over I
said he's putting that paper what he
thought the county needs to know the man
runs a paper route here in this town
thanks very much mr. Dishman good
Fishman's daughter is no longer in
Clinton high school because her father
doesn't want her in a desegregated
school Joanne Allen's father has
withdrawn her for a different reason
they're getting out my name is Herbert
Allen and I've lived in Clinton for 24
years and I found it to be a nice little
town to live in very peaceful very quiet
we've never had any trouble in this
little town thing like this happens
sometime we stay overnight but this
thing is to be and right matches some
doesn't think it should be but God said
he created all men equal and all men
alike and so therefore none of us stands
above the other person in yards site and
we as a Negro race we are only in
Clinton Tennessee abiding by
the Supreme Court ruling that we'd sent
our children to the high school in
Anderson County we haven't broken in law
we had went against the court ruling but
we leave in now for the Los Angeles
California not so much soars because of
this situation but that I might better
myself and that Julianne might have a
little bit more freedom in her school
activities and in her career doing all
the excitement I all the things that the
people are doing I was able to
accomplish something I made two A's and
a B and the only grade grade it was the
C which isn't very bad but I wish it had
been an A or B one my teachers were very
proud of me and my parents were two
because they thought I did well even
throughout the strain that we did have
to go through sometimes I couldn't keep
my mind on my lessons for thinking about
the people on the outside but they were
thinking of and we're not leaving here
with hatred in our hearts against anyone
even those who was against - we do not
hate those people
because we realized that those people
just misled and they was trained and
brought up the way that way yes why did
they were never one able to understand
Clinton High School resumed four days
ago after the scheduled Christmas recess
with 655 students enrolled there were no
incidents some say that the worst is
over that although there is still little
enthusiasm for desegregation there is
now a strong will to comply with the law
there are those in Clinton who say the
big change came when the federal
marshals and the FBI moved it others
among them editor Horace Wells claimant
was Reverend Turner's beating another
thing that has come about and I think
this is largely due through the attacked
on Paul Turner the other day was that
linearis had stood by
unwilling to stand up for integration
and yet also unwilling to violate the
law and when paltin was attacked the the
feeling of the community was more less
solidified no male words could have done
it it took some kind of action a heroic
action something that this being that
was administrative alternate to bring us
to the point where we were willing to
stand up and say now we are not going to
put up with being pushed around anymore
we believe in law and order and that's
what we want that's what we're going to
have and that's the reason that the
people were willing to go to Knoxville
and and put the matter before a federal
judge Taylor and say now we want this
order enforced the trial of the 16
Clinton defendants is set for January 28
there are those who questioned the
legality of the injunction including the
attorneys general of three southern
states and a few colonists the courts
will decide as for Clinton a joint
meeting of the junior and senior
chambers of commerce unanimously adopted
a resolution upholding the desegregation
law in the last four months we've had a
lot of controversial worldwide publicity
on Clinton most of which has been
brought about by a very small minority
of the local citizens most of us are
peaceful law-abiding home loving people
that horrid violence and mob action we
believed in our government and our laws
and the justices handed down by our
courts even though our government and
our laws and our courts don't always
please us as individuals we as Americans
and citizens believe first in both in
personal freedom this personal freedom
is not the freedom to form mobs and take
the law into our own hands but freedom
to think for ourselves and if an issue
doesn't please us to use every legal
peaceful means at our command to change
the issue the Bill of Rights is also a
bill of obligation I read that somewhere
the other day but it's good if there
it today we're not concerned with
whether you are for or against
segregation and we're just concerned
with whether or not you're for or
against law and order that was Clinton
and the law an examination after the
fact of what happened in Clinton
Tennessee this was in no sense an effort
to examine the whole complex problem of
segregation as such in other communities
both the problems and the solutions may
not be identical to those that were
reached in Clinton Tennessee now for see
it now good night and good luck